[موسيقى]
مساكم الله بالخير جميعا واسعد الله هذه
الوجيه لنشوفها امامنا الان ونشكر اخونا
طارق وعلى كل الاخوان والاخوات خلف
الكواليس اللي حقيقه يعني بدلوا مجهود ضخم
جدا شكرا لاخونا صلاح على كلمه اهل رائعه
جدا واللي لمست تويتر حساس جدا باذن الله
اليوم عندي انا موضوع
هو نقطه تحول كانت بالنسبه لي نقطه تحول
فكريه ادت الى فعلا تغيير جسدي وتغيير في
الحياه كامله في مسار الحياه
اذكر قبل 15 سنه من الان بعد تقريبا سبع
سنوات من ممارسه العديد من الهوايات
الخارجيه منها تسلق الجبال
قررت اني اتسلق جبل افرست بحيث اني استطيع
اني امثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واستطيع اني ارفع العلم لاول مره وقابلت
قائد الفريق الكندي وتسلق مشهور كان عمره
54 سنه
فلما وصلت الى قعر جبل ايفرست جلست انا
وياه جلسه اخويه حبيه
وقلت له يتم
ابغى نصيحه
تساعدني حقيقه على الوصول الى قمه جبل
ايفرست
وعلى تخطي هذه العقبات والمعوقات
والصعوبات اللي ممكن تقابلني
فقال لي كلمه او قال لي كلمتين جمله واحده
ضربت في العقل
قال لي فاروق
تحكم
في عقلك
سيطره
على العقل
هي قوه
تعتبر من اقوى القوه
مثل ما قال دانيال
والقوى التي تستطيع فيها تحقيق كل الاهداف
هذه القدره على السيطره على العقل سوف
تغير منظورك للحياه كامله
سوف تجعل امامك العديد من القمم
التي تريد فعلا ان تصل اليها
لان هذه القدره على التحكم وعلى السيطره
على العقل
تغير ايضا في الجسد حيويا في افراز
الهرمونات في افراز الانزيمات في داخل
الجسم في قدرتك على حرق السعرات الحراريه
في مقاومتك للامراض في تحقيق اكل الاهداف
في قدرك لدفع الخواطر السيئه
فجلست اتامل هذه الفكره كيف فعلا يستطيع
الانسان ان يسيطر على عقله كيف يستطيع
العقل ان يسيطر على العقل
وحينما قررت
بان اواصل مسيرتي نحو تلك القمه
ادركت بان هذا الطريق
سوف يكون مليء
بالعقبات والمعوقات والصعوبات التي تقف
حائل بينك وبين الوصول لاعلى القمم بينك
وبين وصول الى اعلى الاهداف بينك وبين
وصول الى الاحلام
الى الطموحات
وصدقوني كلما ارتفعت احلامكم واهدافكم
وقمامكم في الحياه كلما كثرت هذه العقبات
والمعوقات والصعوبات قاعده اساسيه في
الحياه
ولذلك من يخاف وايهاب
ويفقد السيطره على عقله
سوف يضطر الى ان يكون في السهول لانها
سهله
وكما قال الشاعر ومن يتهيب صعود الجبال
يعيش ابدا الدهر بين الحفر لا بل بالعكس
تجده ينتقد من يتسلق ومن يحاول ان يصل
يقول يا اخي هذا وش حاده يا اخي هذا متعبه
يا اخي ناس فاضيه العب العب بس سرى
ينظر الى ان هؤلاء اللي مثلكم وشواكم
اللي جونا من اجل طلب العلم من اجل التزود
من اجل التغيير من اجل قمم في الحياه
ولا ممكن الواحد ممكن يجلس على الشات يجلس
على تيك توك يجلس على الانترنت يوسع صدره
لا
هذه المعوقات وهذه العقبات سوف تقف في
طريق كل واحد منا هذه القاعده رقم واحد
مثلا نحن كمتسلقين كنا نواجه الكثير من
المعوقات اللي اغلبها يتطلب منك قدره
عقليه في التعامل معها
مثل نتكلم عن الارتفاع الضخم حينما تقول
888 متر فوق سطح البحر يعني تتكلم على مثل
برج المملكه الموجود في الرياض 30 مره
هذا معوق نفسي كبير
اذا نظرت الى هذا الارتفاع الضخم
وقلت والله عالي والله صعب
ما في امل
فانت الان
عقلك يتحكم بك ولست انت من يتحكم بالعقل
انت الان تعتبر فاقد للسيطره انت الان
تعتبر راضخ لهذه الخواطر التي قد تاتي
عليك وتحاول احباطك وتكسير مجاديفك
وبالتالي اسقاطك
ومن ضمن هذه العقبات ايضا الانهيارات
الثلجيه
ودرجات الحراره التي قد تصل الى ناقص 70
تحت الصفر
وامراض المرتفعات
وانك قد تكون عرضه للسقوط
من سفح الجبل وانت في طريقك الى القمه
نعم
اذا استمريت في التفكير السلبي في هذه
العقبات والمعوقات اللي بتواجهك في طريقك
نحوك قمه الخاصه فيك انت
قد تترك القمه وتعود اتراجك
ثم المسافه التي تحول بينك وبين هدفك هنا
60 يوم
لكن هدفك قد ياخذ سنين من اجل تحقيقه
هذه كلها اشياء
محبطات معوقات صعوبات
قد تفقد السيطره على هذا العقل
لكن اعظم ما كنا نواجه نحن كمتسلقين
هي المعرفه
بان هناك اكثر
من تقريبا
مئتين جثه تقبع على سفح هذا الجبل نحن
نتكلم على كم نتكلم على تقريبا قبل 15 سنه
الان هذه الجثث اكثر طبعا انا اعرض لكم
صوره هذول الناس الميتين لسبب
ما راح احاول اني اخوفكم ولا اقول لكم ترى
شوفوا فاروق الزمان قوي ما يخاف لا لا
لان حديث النفس
الذي يقع في عقل المتسلق هو نفس الحديث
الذي يقع في عقلك نحن نقارن قد تسمع هذه
الخواطر التي تاتي اليك وتقول لك فاروق
هذا المتسلق الامريكي المشهور اللي تسلق
جبل ايفرست اكثر من مره
ومولود بين الجبال وعنده خبره اكثر من
عقدين من الزمان ولم يستطع الوصول الى
القمه ومات فانت يا من اتيت من الصحراء
وانت اضعف
واقل شهره واقل قدره
بتقدر
فتسمع هذه الخواطر حديث النفس وانت في
اعلى مقبره في هذا العالم
والتي تحاول ان تسقطك
وتثبت عزيمتك نعم انت قد يكون عندك هدف
وانت يكون عندك هدف
ثم تشوف الناس اللي هم انت قد تعتقد انهم
افضل منك واقوى منك واشهر منك واكثر قدرات
ومهارات منك
واغنى منك
لكن هم لم يوفقهم الله في الوصول الى
الاهداف فتبدا تقارن نفسك بهم هذول ما
قدروا
يعني انا بقدر
نعم تقدر
هذه الخواطر
قد تحاول التحكم فيك
لكن المطلوب منك
في انك لا تجعلها تتحكم في قدرتك او في
رغبتك في الوصول الى الهدف الذي تريد نعم
قدرها هؤلاء الميتين على سفع الجبل لكن
اذا قارنت نفسك بهم تنسى
تنسى بان الصانع هو الله عز وجل
تنسى بان نتيجه ليست منك النتيجه من الله
النهايه ليست منك النهايه من الله المطلوب
منك العمل بالاسباب
المطلوب منك التحكم في عقلك نعم نعم انا
اعرف دفع هذه الخواطر يحتاج الى قدرات
كبيره وتمرين كثير وحياه طويله من
المعاناه مع محاوله دفع هذه الخواطر وتحدث
عنها ابن القيم في اكثر من كتاب عن كيف
الانسان يستطيع ان يدفع هذه الخواطر
السيئه
وتحدث عنها الكثير من المفكرين والعلماء
حتى غير المسلمين دفع هذه الخواطر ليست
مهمه اليوم
لكن قدره
على ان لا تجعل هذه الخاطره
تتحكم فيك وفي طريقه نحو القمه هو المطلوب
منك الان
نعم قد تشاهدون ناس كثير ماتوا وهم في
طريقهم نحو تلك القمه لم يوفقهم الله في
التحقيق الاهداف التي تريد ان تحققها
مثلهم
لكن لا تقارن نفسك ابدا في هؤلاء ابدا
لان الله قد يغير الظروف قد يغير الوقت
يغير كل شيء
قد يغلق كل الابواب في وجه اعظم المحترفين
ويفتح الابواب امامك انت
فحينما كنا نشاهد مثل هؤلاء الذين لم
يوفقهم الله عز وجل في تحقيق هذا الاهداف
هنا المطلوب منك قدرات في التحكم بالعقل
هنا القدرات في معرفه كيف تدفع الخواطر
احد هذه القدرات وهي من المهمه جدا هي ان
تدفع السيئه بالحسنه اي بمعنى هذه الخواطر
السيئه التي تجي تقول يا اخي ما راح تقدر
انت رد عليها وتقول الا اكثر
بس انت ضعيف
ولكن القوه من الله
ست ما عندك فلوس
الرازق والله تفتح الابواب
بس انت ما ينقص الكل خبره بتعلمها
دفع هذه الخواطر السيئه بالخواطر الحسنه
او بالتفكير الايجابي مثل ما قال اخوي
صلاح قبل شوي هي قدره وتمرين قد ياخذ عليك
وقت ولكنه ينفعك في هذه الاوقات في
الاوقات التي فعلا تقف امام هؤلاء الناس
الذين لم يوفقهم الله عز وجل
وماتوا وهم في طريقهم نحو القمه
نعم هذه المشاهد قد تكون مخيفه
خصوصا حينما يذوب الثلج وتخرج هذه الجثث
اللي ميت العشرين سنه واللي ميت لها
ثلاثين سنه واللي ميت اهل اربعين سنه
لكن هذه اللحظات هي اختبار حقيقي لك في
قدرتك على التحكم بعقلك
في قدرتك على استرجاع الحديث القدسي الذي
يقول فيه الله عز وجل انا عند ظن عبدي بي
فليظن بي عبدي ما شاء فان ظن خيرا فله وان
ظن شرا فلا يا اخي ليش تظنون ظن السوء
بالله ليش نقول والله شكله قادر
صعبه المجتمع ما يساعد ونبدا نبحث عن
شماعه الاعذار نعم عقلك الذي يبحث
لكنها يرسل لك هذه الرسائل تحكم في هذا
العقل
ابتعد عن كل هذه الشماعات التي تعلق عليها
فشلك فشلت انت المسؤول اخطات انت المسؤول
مو المجتمع مو امك ابوك مو الناس مو زوجك
وزوجتك اولادك الحياه الظروف الفلوس هذه
كلها عقبات وضعت امامك لتختبر
والله عز وجل الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام
ايضا في الحديث الصحيح قال عجبا لامر
المؤمن امره كله ما قال بعضه نصه اغلبه لا
كله له خير ان اصابته ضراء فصبر كانت له
خير وان اصابته
سراء فشكر كانت له خير امرك كله لك خير
لكن تبدا من هنا تبدا من هنا من قدره على
انك تمسك بزمام هذا العقل وتتحكم فيه كما
تتحكم في الفرس في الخيل
تقوده اما ان تقوده اما ان هو يقودك
ويدفعك لان العقل يقاوم الجهد
يقاوم التعب الجسدي والعقلي لذلك تضع يجد
انه يضع امامك الكثير من العقبات
والمعوقات يحاول ان يوقفك نحو تلك القمه
احد ايضا الاشياء اللي كانت تتطلب مهاره
عقليه هو موقف حصل لي حقيقه في العاصمه
كانت منه قبل الانطلاق قابلت رجل كبير في
السن
ابتسم وكان يعني يتملقني ببصره ابتسمت في
وجهه وكنت على عجله من امري حاولت اني
اخرج خارج المحل اللي انا كنت فيه فاوقفني
وقال ماذا تعمل قلت والله اريد ان اتسلق
بعض الجبال هنا في في نيبال قال اي جبل
قلت فوقف الرجل واخذ خطوتين الى الوراء ثم
النظر اسفل اعلى ثم قال لن تستطيع
قلت ليش قال انت اتيت من الصحراء وتريد ان
تتحدى الجليد والثلوج اتيت من درجات حراره
50 فوق الصفر وتريد ان تتحدى درجات حراره
50 تحت الصفر
وانا مولود في الجبال
وحاولت اتسلك جبل افرست اكثر من مره ولم
استطع
ثم اعطاني ظهره وخرج من هذا المحل هذولي
الناس موجودين في حياتنا اليوميه من يحاول
ان يكسر مجايفك من يشكك في قدرتك على
تحقيق هدف معين
طريقه التعامل مع هؤلاء هي مثل ما تعامل
الانبياء كلا ان معي ربي سيهدين هكذا قال
موسى حينما كان البحر امامه والجيوش خلفه
لا تحزن ان الله معنا هكذا قال عليه
الصلاه والسلام حينما كان الكفار قريش عند
باب
الجبل وكانوا ينظرون الى الرسول ينظرون
الى الفتحه من الاسفل ويكادون انهم يرون
الرسول عليه الصلاه والسلام اني اعلم من
الله ما لا تعلمون هكذا هي الحياه
هذا التمسك وهذه القدره على السيطره على
العقل يجعل طموحك ليس له نهايه ويجعل
القدراتك على التغلب على هؤلاء المحبطين
لا تعد ولا تحصى مهما كانت هذه العقبات
التي سوف تواجهك وانت في طريقك نحو قمتك
الخاصه
لذلك التفكير الايجابي
ومحاوله دفع الخواطر السلبيه وانت في
طريقك نحو هذا الهدف هي اعظم ما سوف
يساعدك في تحقيق هذه الاهداف في الحياه
لذلك قدرتك على التحكم بالعقل سوف تساعدك
كثيرا في تخطي هذه العقبات المتواجه في
الحياه هذه الحفر
هذه الثلوج هذه الصعوبات
حتى ياتي اليوم والتي تجتاز في كل هذه
العقبات باذن الله ثم تقف على القمه وانت
في غايه السعاده وليست ولم يكن هدفك فقط
هو الوقوف على هذه القمه بل كانت هذه
الرحله بكاملها
هي السعاده الحقيقيه بانك تعرف بانك كنت
انت المسيطر سالوا ادموند هلري هو اول من
تسلف جبل افرست
وقالوا
انت تحكمت او انت سيطرت على الجبل
قال لا انا سيطرت على عقلي طيب بمعنى
تحكمت على عقلي وبالتالي استطعت اني اسيطر
على هذا الجبل واصل الى القمه
هؤلاء السلبيين الموجودين في الحياه وهذه
العقبات والمعوقات كل ما تتظلمه منك هي
قدره فقط واحده وهي قدره التحكم بالعقل
اذا ما استطعت باذن الله انك تتحكم في هذا
العقل سوف يعينك الله عز وجل بانك ترى كل
ما تراه في امامك على ان عقبه على ان محفز
للوقوف على القمه يوما ما وتحقيق كل
الاهداف التي تريدها باذن الله
هذا وصلى الله على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين شكرا لكم وشكرا للاستماعكم